this past weekend
[Music]
there's a nice one huh
that's a nice one right there
oh holy night
[Music]
that's a good one right there and that
is oh holy night as a beautiful song
right there and it is by Johannes boar
loaf born born loaf yo.hannes
born loaf and he's coming to us live
from another country not live but he was
live at one point johannes born sounds
dead like he might actually be deceased
these days thank you guys for joining me
merry almost Christmas Happy Holidays
whatever you celebrate I hope you got a
little bit of joy in you that's oh holy
night right there and now I think
they're talking about the night of our
dear saviors birth that's what they're
going into there you know and I think
that's just that night where you know
that baby shows up where that baby shows
up and that baby they're talking about
the dang Lord you know they're talking
about that Mulligan you know they're
talking about humanity's Mulligan when
God was like dang this ain't going so
hot I'm gonna have I'm gonna send
somebody trooper I'm a sim a little
super trooper down there to shake it up
shake it up and that's when we got the
Lord and he showed up as a baby you know
the Lord showed up as a dang baby and
people don't think about that sometimes
you know cuz if I should like if I if I
go into battle if I'm going out there to
get things done if I you know I'm saying
heck if I even go outside and it's
raining I need a umbrella if I even you
know if it's gonna be dusty I need to
you know um have special goggles you
know if I'm going that you know if I'm
going into a scary area I might take a
bow and arrow or take a little hatchet
but to think that the Lord showed up out
here
he showed up out here as a baby to do
battle and that's the sneaky and that's
beautiful and that's one thing that I
think sometimes about you know when you
get into these stories of into these
religious tales you know and you hear
you hear them in your and you know it
they're all kind of like a they're all
you know fables if you will and I'm not
saying that you know I'm not I'm not
commenting on religion here they're all
stories that's what I'm saying they're
all stories they're all histories that
are meant to teach us something you know
no matter what book you're reading the
story in or no book at all but I do
believe you're out there running
freelance without any higher power in
your life good luck out there okay
because you're trying to work an iPhone
without a charger cable far as I'm
concerned but it is interesting when you
think about that the Lord showed up as a
dang baby to do battle dude that's the
last thing I would do it just doesn't
seem it's you know well first of all
nobody expects it so it's crafty that's
crafty but you're just so you don't have
any real I mean your special skills or
crying you know cuteness you know you
know making noises cute noises that's
like your basically your superpowers
cute noises and burping I mean that was
the Lord's super powers when he showed
up as a baby you know and that's just
brave I think I think it's brave to show
up and do battle to take the take away
the sins of the world as a dang baby you
know spider-man was Peter Parker you
know Clark Kent you know at least
Superman his he started off he worked at
a newspaper but the Lao showed up and
said you know what send me in as a baby
and I'm still gonna get the job done so
I got to say world's most successful
baby or on
preneur is a human the Lord and it's
that time of year man and that's what
they're talking about that oh holy night
and it's just about you know how you
show up how do you show up and this
holiday season that's what I'm thinking
about you know it's been a tough year
for me it's been a tough year I feel
like to be a man you know we've
discussed that over the year and you
know we've all thought about it we've
had a lot of callers and it's been tough
and I'm tried constantly I'm tried I'm
tried by my own ego I'm tried by the
world I'm tried by others everything
tries me you know tries to get me to
step outside of my goodness you know try
to give me to step outside and be
reaching out in the dark arts you know
and reaching in you know supposed to
just be at the fridge to get a sip of
milk but next thing you know I'm in the
cheese drawer and I got a knife and I'm
cutting little pieces of cheese in my
mouth or I'm doing something that I
shouldn't be doing and that's what I
find a lot of times is that it's hard
for me to stay in stay in my zone stay
in my manhood and just toe the line it's
tough it's tough out there it is tough
out there and a show-up is a baby and to
toe the line I think you know that's
pretty cool and it's a powerful story
you know and also to be born out there
in a desert man I mean that's crazy
I mean I know good and well have you
seen a baby out in Arizona dude you go
out there to bet out towards Bisbee
Arizona out there towards outside of
Glendale where it hits a hundred and
thirty do you see a baby out there look
like a damn lizard I mean they got
babies out there weigh four or five
pounds and they're probably about nine
months old you know you got a lot of
babies that look like smokers okay
you've been smoked as cigarettes
and there you know scaly you know I'm
saying you got it you got a little bit
of you know there bait you know there
they got it they got that lizard in them
they got long tongues I mean it's it's
hard to be a baby in a desert because
you need milk and barely have anything
you can even get milk out of in a desert
you know and it's uh it's that time of
year though I said oh holy night and I
like hearing that one on Christmas Eve
and on Christmas time and you know and I
picture myself you know doing something
romantic
you know honestly and and that's why I
guess what I'm thinking about right now
I'm thinking about holidays are this
week you know I guess it's got to get
through this week and how am I gonna
show up as a man and do what I gotta do
you know cuz I need to I need to be
there if I got a family I need to be
there you know I got to treat my spouse
or my significant other with some
respect one thing you can definitely do
is I noticed if you get your ladies a
gift don't use the same wrapping paper
that you use for the children's stuff
dude get your girls something nice get
her some nice paper or something
sentimental you know wrap it in a you
know maybe her favorite shirt or your
favorite shirt tape it up you know and
just use different things and use for
the children's stuff show her that you
did that a little bit extra
or if you dating a man if you got a man
that's a lover you know if you're in
love with someone that's just like you
which i think is that's the only thing
that the some time about homosexuality
it's a little-bitty go it's a little bit
egotistical you know oh yeah I'm there I
think I'm such a great man I'm gonna
love another man that's the part
sometimes to me but you got to show up
this year as a man and that's what I'm
trying to do trying to get out there you
know and let my small breasts out these
are baby a-cups I got you know it's
tough out there it's tough but you got
to spin a little bit of time with your
lady maybe take a walk with her hold her
hand take over when was the last time
you tickled your lady or your husband
snuck up in the kitchen and tickle a
[ __ ] boy get the giggles out
that [ __ ] make a bubble at the [ __ ]
mouth you tickle them and love them just
Shh you [ __ ] shake them boy I'm a
meter stick boy one time I think I've
told this story try started tickling me
early in the morning and a hot tub one
time on
ship and I'm trying to keep him off and
his body was all hot you know he had
them kind of kid tits on he was thick
thick beau a Midwestern boy you know I'm
talking South Iowa boy you know I'm
saying where the gristle don't miss you
and uh and he had that he had that just
that guns up under his chin you know he
had that neck belly that Nellie you know
and he arm or that Sorelli maybe that
throat belly
he had that thrilly and I had to I had
to grab him by that thrilly and keep him
all for me but because he was in the
warm water in the hot tub he was getting
handprints and stuff all for me
defending myself because this boy was
tickling me which i think is shady to be
tickling somebody don't know you tickle
a loved one or you tickle a kid at a
party you know where you tickle an old
man if they're you know sleeping on a
plane or something you're trying to
liven them up but you don't just tickle
[ __ ] just you know you just don't
tickle an adult if you're a kid unless
you're trying to I think get that money
I think in hindsight this boy was trying
to get me to get Randy with him so then
it looks like I'm trying to you know be
weird around children you know next
thing you know he shows up he gets out
of the hot tub he's got my handprints
all over him from defending myself and
next thing you know I'm guilty I'm
guilty I look because it's obviously
looks like I've been touching him
because his body holds a lot of
handprints because he got that you know
that gristle that hot when you're when
you when you got a little bit of meat on
you in a little bit of thickness when it
heats up you can leave handprints on it
and uh that's just a trial that I went
through and that was last year but yeah
it's time to show up and be a man so you
just you got to do something special
with your lady you got a tickler you
know touch her neck you know touch her
ears man you know touch it but when's
the last time you touched your lady's
ears or your husband if you got a little
husband you know it's time it's that
time of year to show up like a man maybe
do a little bit of recommitment tear to
your loved one or tell your kid you love
them again because I've never had a
child do but I've been around some
children
and sometimes it's hit or miss you know
I was with a group the other day and
there was a man who you know admitted
that he hadn't really loved us he had
never really loved his son because his
son didn't really wasn't really the way
that he wanted his son to be and that
shook me down you know I never even had
a child but you know it's just crazy too
it's just a heavy thought to think that
that kind of stuff goes on out there and
there's nothing we can do about it
sometimes just the way we are you know
we just have to manage it you know if we
got an infection or we got an affliction
and we got a little bit of the dark arts
you know we got that fancy nasty just
nipping at our neck if that fancy nasty
monster is nipping at your neck
sometimes you just have to just shake it
off and you got to stand there and do
whatever man have to do and be a man you
know that's why I'm mad but I wish
everybody a happy holiday season you
know be that baby show up and be that
wild baby I mean you know I'm saying
Jesus Christmas was a beautiful baby I
mean that baby showed up in the desert
had a couple of old dudes walked out to
the middle of the desert to meet a baby
now 100% illegal to do that 100% illegal
in fact it's a TV show now hell if
you're an old man even going to meet a
14 year old for some lemonade or
whatever they bust you so the fact that
three old men were cruising out into the
desert to meet a child that is that's us
that's a crime now that's wild to think
that what was a ridge what was what what
is the story of one of the most popular
religions is now a crime and they got
sheep they're in animals you can't have
children around livestock I know there's
some you know in some states or some
legal issues about that if you're trying
to transport them across state lines and
stuff so who knows who knows but I think
if the if the Lord ever come back it's
gonna be through alien or how else could
he come back maybe portal wishing well
I don't know he could fly out of elon
musk's nutsack I bet
who knows how he could come back but
it's nice to think it's exciting and
it's exciting and that's what we got to
do this holiday season as fellows we got
to stay in there and stay excited you
got to show up get up get active don't
be thinking don't be begrudging go to
your mother-in-law's before you get
there it's not the same old visit it's
hitting the same busy you went last week
it's hitting the same visit you went two
weeks ago there's a special morning you
got to make it special make it special
for your spouse make it special for your
children your animal put a jingle bell
on your animal if you got a special
animal put a couple jingle bells on his
ass you don't say him show up and do
what you have to do as a man you gonna
make mistakes dude I made a mistake
earlier I had a you know I've always run
out of gas in my life and with
automobile I'll run out of automobile
gas and most automobiles run on gas dude
and and I'd love to have one of the
future cars that do not where they're
running on electricity or some of them
are just running on good ideas or just I
don't know they got some out here some
of these little coasters you know looks
like somebody got a little coffee filter
on wheels out here and that thing looks
like it's running on a couple of dudes
dry humping in the trunk I don't know
how those things are running what energy
those are running on but you wanna oh
but it's off run out of gas a lot of my
life ever since I was a child I didn't
know that people didn't run out of gas
you know a lot of times I would see
people on the side of the road and I
always thought oh they ran out of gas
you know and I've run out of gas you
know I ran out of gas probably about 20
25 times before I knew I told a buddy of
mine and this was in college it's like
damn man I called him like a run out of
gas I'm and he's like why the GAM out
man fresh out you know and he said what
the [ __ ] you're fresh out of gas so yeah
you know the car only hold so much most
of the car is empty space you know the
trunk they could put gas in there but
they don't and he's like you're a
[ __ ] idiot bro and anyway he came to
pick me up but it was wild because at
that point he's realizing that
that uh I'm realizing that a lot of
people don't run out of gas that much
but yeah I ran out of ton remember one
time we ran out at a summer camp and I
had a bunch of the kids help me push the
car and everybody's parents got upset
and I blamed it on a friend of mine and
I think he actually got laid off but he
also was throwing rocks at some of the
children he said it was like a game they
were playing but I don't think that's
you know it's not a fun idea to be
throwing rocks at other people's kids
especially not from close up you know
it's dangerous but I have a little cafe
here I'm sitting here and I'll tell you
one thing I'm gonna tell you about how I
spilled gasoline in my trunk but first
I'm gonna tell you about that great
block pizza and we always were so
grateful to our charter sponsor that
grey block pizza and that's at 1811 Pico
Boulevard here in Los Angeles when you
don't on your way to the beach you know
I'm saying before you even get there
open your mouth walk inside look at the
menu look the order personalized tell
them to fill you fill you up get that
hitter great block pizza the link will
be in our notes here for the episode and
they got beautiful pies over there
and that's Italian full time food that's
24/7 pizza some food you can't be like
that now and laters when do you eat them
it's hard to decide you have one in the
morning you are your [ __ ] creep you
have a couple maybe in the afternoon
nobody eats now and laters at midnight
some case you know some foods you can't
have all the time but pizza is that
great block provides it I uh I ran out
of gas right so I I decided I'm gonna
get a can of gas and put it in the trunk
of my car cuz I've ran out of gas
twice this year so I decided I'm put a
can of gas in the trunk of my car I'll
put it in there and I guess the thing
wasn't all the way locked in on the top
the lid the the top so I've been driving
around for two days man I opened that
thing up to that sort of smelling
gasoline and open that up
whoo boy that trunk is ready that trunk
is ready
for something you know that trunk is
ready to do a little 911 you know in 912
that thing is already I could look I'll
sell that to a to an angry Saudi Arabia
and I bet I'll sell that car to an angry
Saudi Arabian for top dollar because
that thing is oh that thing is it's
Wilin out so I'm gonna leave the trunk
open while I'm out of town over the
holidays because I'm going back to
Louisiana tomorrow I'm gonna leave the
trunk open and let some of that gasoline
get out of there cuz I probably spilled
it probably at least a half gallon
they got bounced around in that trunk
but yeah I didn't realize a lot of
people don't run out of gas and you know
what I'm still gonna do stuff like that
I'm still that doesn't make me not a man
if I do that kind of thing you know if
you run out of gas with your family just
tell me yeah that's fine you know y'all
be cute put on hats get out there
hitchhike anybody would pick up a
beautiful family and some hats that's
easy that's an easy one but still show
up be a man be who you are be a man do
what you have to do and sometimes you
gotta you know you got to admit to admit
when you're wrong you know and last week
I you know I talked about a caller
called in and I had who'd brought a date
to the show it was a first date and he
called in a long time with us a long
time ago and and I had his girlfriend
hit me up over you know some social
media or something or no they got my
number
his girlfriend hit me up or the date hit
the date not the girlfriend hit me up
and uh and you know she offers some
sensuality and I I took it I agreed to
it you know I knew it was wrong I knew
that I've met these people hung out with
them and the next thing you know you
know I'm out there trying to cultivate
this lady and um and I felt bad about it
we had some calls that came in about it
you know some of our listeners weren't
happy I'm a comment on that in a second
but here's a guy who called in he called
him a couple of times as he heard the
episode from last from last week he
called in a few times here it is serious
dude I just had to turn the podcast off
because I
you just lost a fan man this is Joe from
Pittsburgh and I just heard you talking
about how you [ __ ] this dude's
girlfriend
knowingly you knew exactly what the
situation was you went out with these
people you went to the bar you hung out
and he went behind the suits back and
you [ __ ] this girl he said he wasn't
even a good time dang man hearing you
say it like that Joe is he making me
feel like a child you know you really
ought making me feel like a child and I
guess you know it was childish behavior
you know I was childish behavior
homework time so basically working a
worth it do you got me so heated I had
to call back and leave a second message
this is his second call Joe called three
times and I just can't stop thinking
about the story you just told about
[ __ ] this guy's girlfriend and he
keeps using the word [ __ ] and look I
appreciate you calling Joe and I'm
playing this because I want you know I
want to hear what you guys think I want
to hear what you guys thoughts are and I
want to you know I want to know and I
you know I'm not gonna I don't want to
shy away from what's going on with me
but I'll see you say [ __ ] a lot buddy
and I wouldn't call what I do in the bed
always [ __ ] you know I would
definitely call it you know sporting
around with my dick or [ __ ] you know or
entertaining a vagina but definitely
[ __ ] is something like I feel like a
brother does or like you know a real
hearty Italian you know uh are those
really skinny Polish dudes on the
internet them dudes my god man are they
up they look like they're powered by
hydro electricity you know they just
they just got that one pump just going
you know but that's not what I do boy
I'm that you know I'm that shifty
grifter when it comes down to being
involved with the but the body parts you
know I'm not uh I wouldn't call it a I
wouldn't call sex my expertise at all
I'm a novice [ __ ] you know I've been
in there I've been out in there mom and
them cooter streets you know I've been
out in them cooter streets in them
bootie byways you know
but I'm definitely a novice I'm not that
it's just not my finest attribute my
sexual abilities now sometimes I'll get
out there and you know I'm saying
sometimes they order they think they're
getting that Miyagi and I'll hit them in
the cooter with that Karate Kid you know
with that [ __ ] rowdy high yeah but let's
hear more Joe but at the [ __ ] you're
making me feel at you you almost give me
too much credit homeward
I can't maybe she wasn't girlfriend but
they were obviously together they were
out together you knew it you know men
are supposed to be hunters I can't
imagine that you can't go out and find
your own chick it's kind of like walking
into somebody else's house and shooting
their cat instead of there's going out
into the jungle and hunting a real tiger
I don't know if it's like that but let's
hear more all right deal had some time
to cool down still a little upset still
gonna be a fan once the tiny sand who
hit me I knew I had to call back and can
just let you know that I still don't
approve well I appreciate that Joe I I
do appreciate your call you know and I
thing is like I thought you know for a
while it didn't put that call on but
then I just felt like I had to you know
if I'm gonna talk about if I'm gonna
expect callers to call them about real
stuff that's going on in their lives and
I'm gonna put some of their lives not on
blast but on you know if we're putting
[ __ ] out there and I'm putting it out
there you know I feel like what is our
life if we're not really sharing what's
really going on or trying our best to
share what's really going on dude trust
me
I'm just trying my best to share you
know I'm there's some stuff that you
know I don't know if I'll ever be able
to get out of my mouth or get out of my
heart
forget out of my brain you know there's
some stuff that is inside of me that I
don't even know what it is you know so
I'm just gonna do the best articulate
what I can in the mean time and I might
you know there's gonna be a lot of stuff
I'll probably do wrong
and this is the thing that I did wrong
you know I hooked up with this dudes
girl that he brought to the show
that's [ __ ] up man it's douchebag it's
douchebag stuff like imagine I go to one
I take a girl to a dude show and and I
take a girl to a dude show and next
thing you know you know I find out later
then I go on a second date with her and
I found out she hooked up with that with
the dude whose show I took her to man
yeah so I mean sometimes we have to we
need other people to show us what our
behavior is and to really give us a look
and so I'll just come in that guy for
calling in originally and for uh you
know and for telling and for you know
putting me in my place because the next
time that that opportunity presents
itself I'm not going to present myself
to that opportunity you know and I've
made you know I've made look dude I've
had some addictive behaviors when it's
come to women in the past for sure and I
still struggle with it today I remember
a time I was living with this fella and
he used to train we didn't train cats
but he would smoke some marijuana and I
would smoke some but I didn't like
smoking marijuana with this boy mister
Khin in his name with mister Khin and he
actually did some karate and he had some
cats and he had these his two cats had
already lived with him and then i moved
in and took the second bedroom so i
don't have any say in the cat's I can't
move in and like oh what are these cats
doing here living with us because the
cats already lived there they were his
cats he was a cat owner which is how
that's even a real term in the universe
cat owner yeah for now dude to mother
nature [ __ ] strikes back and they got
lions eating [ __ ] you know they got
Lions getting you know just just
chomping down on the spines of the you
know of whites and Koreans out on the
street out on the streets of Memphis and
streets of anywhere then we'll see who's
a cat owner you because mother nature's
about to [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody up but
anyhow Kent
Mr Kim would get high and he would make
me come out in the liver me to have all
these empty boxes stacked up and he
would the cats would climb up and get in
the boxes you know I guess one of them
was kind of a show cat and the other one
was just kind of a secondary cat that
seemed a little bit supportive of the
first cat and would do some of the same
type
mr. Kent called him tricks I didn't
think it were tricked you know watching
a cat when I'm hired two cats getting
into a box that shit's [ __ ] stupid to
me but I guess I you know I felt I felt
a little scare to Ken because his do we
do karate in the house we're both adults
man this is if we were 30 so when you're
doing karate in the house and you know
y'all just just met you know there's
definitely there's something going on
there you know that's that [ __ ]
that's when somebody's nipping yeah
that's when somebody's catching a little
bit of the you know they might have a
little bit of you know they might have
the dam they might have a you know
something loose in their spine or
something in their brain stem might not
be on 100 you know they might have some
of that uh ape glue or whatever it's
called keeping their brain stem locked
into their spine but he uh so anyway we
gotta for watch these cats get high and
whatever [ __ ] but yeah that's what
I'm talking about man [ __ ] I forgot what
is even talking about just now
mother nature talking about the cat's I
was talking about I had that roommate
can and that fellow who oh you said it's
like a tiger it's like a cat man yeah I
don't think it's like going into
somebody's house and shooting a cat you
know I think it's just that oh oh oh
let's telling you this so Ken mr. Ken
the dude who I lived with one time I was
moving out I'm moving out of the place
right and nobody had come has seen the
apartment I'm showing the room he's been
advertising it because his name is on
the lease so I'm showing it and this hot
chick comes over and she she told she I
showed the room and I started flirting
with her man because I couldn't help
myself
you know sometimes I just cannot help
myself and and Ken told me oh I ended up
getting her number
and Ken told me she left he's like man
she's really interested in the place she
seemed really cool do not don't hook up
with this girl man do not hook up with
this girl
and I said okay can I won't
I promise that I won't man and then a
few hours later whatever she and I are
texting I invite her out to do we went
and did something or whatever then she
came back to the place with me the room
she was considering renting and we made
love you know we made second you know we
made first degree or second degree love
because I don't like I told you man I
don't shift into high gears when it
comes to sex boy you know I'm saying I'm
that artful I got that artful Idol I got
that attack Idol but I don't have that
third and fourth gear you know I'm
saying you might find me strutting out
in second but you're not gonna see me in
third or fourth you know but yeah I've
ended up banging this young lady you
know and Kim was pissed
Kim was pissed man and I think actually
she ended up giving me the whatever the
the club whatever the one is you got to
get salt pills or whatever to get rid of
it's an infection in your wiener but
it's something you can that you can get
cured real easy penicillin cures it they
don't really have it anymore but it used
to be popular back in the day and she
and I split a case of that but yeah you
know it's uh it's obviously been
something I've struggled with in the
past and I think it's just that I'm I
have to you know I feel guilty I don't
know I don't I just have to I need some
attention you know there's something
inside of me that's that's that's broken
or something that needs some attention
and and I need it from women I guess and
sometimes I make poor choices because of
that because of that inside of me but
you know it's gotten less and less over
the years and it's something that I'm
aware of now but I'm you know I'm far
from perfect but I'm gonna put my stuff
out there on this cast and especially if
I'm gonna expect you guys to do the same
so I appreciate your call Joe I'm sorry
yet that I you know I didn't live up to
your expectations but I promise you that
I'll probably won't live up to him again
man you know I really probably won't so
let's keep it cruising right here we got
a rap that
came in I haven't heard it yet we're
gonna hear it for the first time
together here's a rap that came in about
last week's episode my favorite
comedians name is Theo von
I always be laughing whenever he go
along I download the episode as soon as
it's ops is here that celebrate living
baby right from the top hitter this past
weekend was amazing she got so hungry
that he almost ate an Asian he'd go to
Denny's even though he [ __ ] hates it
because he always sees a beer on his
waitress you got a problem with his hair
you should save it he knows it sucks
he's just trying to make a statement
he used the jerk himself I might he used
to spank him if brother tried to touch a
dick under a blanket
yeah and that was I think that was
during one of the holiday seasons all
word okay he wishes that his neck was
just a bit longer take your date to his
show he might dong her whoo-hoo-hoo this
J savage coming in with this and I
haven't heard this yet you know the the
guys we got helping out now pull this
out of the the hotline and put it out
for me and there's more let's go Gillis
College eyes cuz that's the dark arts
like people calling in and saying that
they eat parts drug-induced a sex at a
rest stop but they resume aggressively
and just wow we poppin off about the
rest areas and we used to shoot potatoes
at uh they used to have gave me a
meeting up behind the rest areas and
hugging when I was growing up and some
people he's just shoot potatoes at him
and we got involved in that one time
accidentally people was kind of like a
local pyramid scheme and you know we
didn't know we're going onward as
children onward my dude Theo is a
hamster expert a guinea pig prodigy he's
really smart you would think he had a
law degree
someone should give his ass a PhD in
mockery he talked about his feelings and
that really means a lot to me but it's
been in bed with [ __ ] Joan Rivers
coming to the stage is a stone-cold
killer so go ahead and drop his ass a
couple billers on patreon because there
ain't nobody really do great block J
savage Peter
without tiny Sandhu I'll ask your boy
wow that's awesome J I appreciate that
that's Jay salvage coming in here wow
man I covered
I felt like my whole life you know when
your mother I don't know if some of you
guys had this and this this is a
blessing my mother made a baby book for
me when I was young you know my mother
uh we never been really close in in our
hearts I don't think but my mother when
I look back she did she made this baby
book for me sometimes when I feel really
disconnected I'll go read it you know
and I'll you know if I just need proof
sometimes that you know that my mother
cared about me when I was when I was a
kid and I can ask her she'll say yes of
course but sometimes I need I don't know
something's wrong with me sometimes and
I need more I need more than that and so
I'll go read this baby book and my
mother was very meticulous at writing
down you know little pieces of my life
and things and stuff like that and and
uh and it makes me feel a little more
whole just everything like you know Theo
was you know 27 inches today and he
doesn't he likes to touch his feet or
you know he will chew on the edge of his
shirt and he smiles when when I turn on
the light in the room were little things
like that that just you know made me may
when I look back on I know that she was
very aware of me and you might think
well that's stupid of course your mother
was aware of you you were a child but
you know sometimes when you struggle
with addiction and those sorts of things
there's something inside of you that's
that's broken right around that area
where you don't feel that all the time
and if you don't if you don't feel that
all the time then you need reinforcement
which is why people like me go to
different you know groups or you know
seek out therapy stuff like that but J
what I'm getting to J is that this was
almost like that a little bit man this
was fun and this was real and I really
appreciate it this is a I got a lot of
nice calls this week people just saying
thank you and people saying they love
the podcast and you know people giving
some ideas and what we can do for the
new year and we got things going on
behind the scenes here we got things
you know gray blots coming in and
supporting us and helping us get to you
know we're expand we're gonna be able to
get some guests in for the second
episode each week and we have some fun
ideas we're starting to implement them
we've had fans reach out with you know
I've had about eight producers that
reached out bud Galloway Chris you know
Shai Chris and he's uh he's a Latino and
you know it's just we got people on
helping out now and it's it's coming
along and this is awesome J thank you
because I know you obviously spent some
time doing this and we'll go out on it
again maybe at the end today
if not I'll put this up separately on
the YouTube so people can check it out
but thank you for that Jay it's just
nice you went through it it was real you
know we talked about the highs and the
lows in there some things that make me
feel good and some things that make me
just feel you know and sometimes for me
it's just about feeling if I can feel I
just need to feel you know it doesn't
matter if it's something that feels you
know there were times in my life where I
just needed to be mean I needed to you
know I needed to there are times where I
just need to feel like people loved me
immediately you know I need to feel the
affections of women I need to feel like
everybody's my friend I need to feel
supported I mean [ __ ] I have a disease
where I need to be onstage you know
being a stand-up comedian is an
affliction I have to I have to I have to
go into a room with a couple hundred
people that I do not know every night
and get and I need them to laugh at me
so I can go home and and lay in bed and
feel okay people always like do you feel
on top of the world there's about four
or five seconds when I get offstage
where I feel in my body a it's not a
superpower but it's a it's an elevated I
feel elevated within my skin and my
spirit but then after that I just feel
okay
I just feel okay which is all I'm ever
just trying to feel anyway you know I'm
not even in this world a lot of times to
try and feel good my biggest battle and
the toughest thing for me to feel in
this world is just to have been to feel
okay
but you guys are helping me and I
appreciate that J savage we got another
call that came in right here I want to
get to us just keeping the vibe going
here on this Christmas and showing up
like men and here's a man showing up
right now and ask him for some help with
something that's going on with him let's
go
hey yo this is Matt in Cleveland you
said to call maybe if you had some
addictions you're dealing with and my
addiction is a little strange you know
I'm a big guy and I just have a really
bad food addiction eating are you on
that food you got calorie power boy huh
let's hear more really bad food and you
think it would be as simple as just you
know not eating bad food but I genuinely
do not like healthy food at all I don't
like salads I don't like any of that
stuff I don't really like plain water
plain water that's just water so I was
wondering you know maybe what your
advice is for someone who is having a
hard time you know trying to eat and be
healthy in their life when the stuff
that you know it's better form is just
not very appealing okay this is a good
and this is a good question you know
what I'll do this I'll do for you this
won't be until January because I'm going
home and I'll do an episode from home
but I'm going to have other callers call
in and who might know more about this I
know we have some Fitness guys out there
who were in that universe and this is
something we you know we all struggle
with do we all want that snack you know
we all want that piece of nast Nast up
under our tongue you know if you telling
me [ __ ] set up I mean look even if
you tell me feel that bucket set a
celery stick on top of my tongue or two
hits I a sit under it I'll take two hits
of acid you know I used to eat acid so
yeah I know look you talking to a man
who's got some rough eating habits so I
feel you if you rather have a hot dog or
a footlong dog you know or you rather
have a little stack of grilled turkey
necks or some grilled cheeses are you
just [ __ ] waking up in the middle of
the night and crack and open a can of
soup from the side and just getting that
hitter you know that's your life man
but you're reaching out now because you
wanna you want to see how can I get out
how can I evolve out of this I'm gonna
tell you first of all I mean if you have
a real addiction to it then there's
groups there's a group somewhere you can
get into for food addiction you know
snackers anonymous you know chocoholics
you know people that's [ __ ] you know
hiding grilled cheeses and you know
cheesy sticks in their ass some people
don't even want to eat they just put the
food right in their ass bruh so there's
all types of people out there that have
problems so that's okay it's okay to
have a problem you trying to get past
you trying to figure it out and I think
it's well step program could really help
you but otherwise maybe some people out
there know so some guys hit the hotline
you know nine eighty five six six four
nine five zero three Matt likes to eat
the [ __ ] you know and I feel you dude
you don't think I want to [ __ ] yeah look
I'll say this all the time I don't want
to eat that turkey salad I don't want to
eat that tuna fish cut sandwich you know
I don't want to get the you know when I
go to Wendy's you know I don't want to
get the salad and get a burger but throw
the bun out and break the meat up and
put it on the salad you know I want to
get the [ __ ] chili bruh and I want to
pull out you know we used to try to do
the whole thing of chili in one big gulp
and burn our throats you know playing
hot canal me and my brother and his
friend Jeremiah we just play hot canal
that's when you get that chili from
Wendy's pinch your nose off and just
take that bang take that douse boy but
you can't do that [ __ ] at a certain
point you got to start taking care of
yourself so how do you do that you gotta
find some substitutions you gotta find
things that that entice you about eating
healthy but look man I say this all the
time I'd love to go lay in the park and
shoot dope I'd love to be jacked up on
heroin you know and babysitting I'd love
to get a damn eight-ball and sit in a
hammock and take a [ __ ] nap
pick that in
scible nap because i'll be that
impossible nap or boy i'll be that
[ __ ] nap MacGyver people like you
can't sleep on this you can't sleep on
this eight ball you can't sleep on this
ass and watch me watch me work watch me
catch these Z's you know we we but but
but what I'm saying to you is I can't do
that because we have to aim to better
ourselves somewhat and I know that's why
you're calling and I don't really have
the answer for you except that I know
it's possible and you got to find some
ways to do it I would start with fruits
may have vegetables [ __ ] I don't like
a lot of vegetables but I always start
with fruits juice and stuff juicing is
good you know getting some carrots I'll
you could put peanut butter on any
vegetable it's pretty good except for
you know just peanut butter and spinach
not that great but let's see if some
colors come in I'll call for you Matt
and I appreciate you calling me because
that's a real addiction food you know I
want to be that [ __ ] sugar bear you
know I want to [ __ ] lay on my back
and spread my [ __ ] open to have
somebody pour [ __ ] honey in it you
know I want to I live a sweet tooth man
I got sweet teeth in my ass it seems
like I want them sugar doughnuts you
know I want them snacky breads I want
all of that I don't want that powerful
[ __ ] cinnamon glaze
I'll let somebody take a can of [ __ ]
creme brulee painting paint the inside
of my mouth with that [ __ ] I want that
sugar I want that affliction you know I
want it all but you know laughter I have
to do something better for myself and
you can too and you will and let's see
if we can help Lola will have people hit
the hotline all right guys I appreciate
you guys calling this just this
follow-up episode from last week and I
appreciate it and I just want to say
Merry Christmas to everybody happy
Holidays to everybody be a man show up
that's all you got to do you don't have
to do anything crazy you just have to
show up you just have to show up be of
service help out help out help somebody
hug somebody extra bring two extra hugs
to every party you go to and hug a
[ __ ] you know my thing hug
somebody that
don't like you that's my thing get it on
video send it in to me and I'll make
sure to post that thing
hashtag hug somebody that hates you but
I want to thank I want to thank
everybody oh I got a couple of Christmas
gifts I want to tell you about them
really quick so I got one came in I
already opened it up and open it on the
patreon man and these are the kind of
things you get to see on the patreon
open it up on there and I talked more
about it but I just thought it was so
nice I wanted to tell about it on here
and it's uh they said hey Theo what's up
cat daddy I'm glad this could actually
become full circle I'm a huge fan of
comedy podcast and listen to them as I
do my side gig here and make these
candles and this man is a candle man a
lot of y'all might think man make
candles yeah men out there making
[ __ ] candles why because they won't
let us be warlords anymore because they
won't let us throw axes at our neighbors
anymore and shoot people with archery so
this man made these beautiful candles
and this he asked me what kind of wanted
I wanted a root beer come I mother used
to give me root beer candies sometimes
when we were going road trips and she
used to sell cookies and I would go
along with her and sell cookies and
she'd give me a root beer candies to
keep me off of the cookies but this one
called the Reverend Avery brewing he's
our out of Boulder Colorado and I like
these he goes I hope you enjoy be good
to yourself because you probably deserve
it and thank you for this candle it's
the root beer candle and I keep it on my
desk here thank you very much as well
what else did I get
oh I got a really cool pillow and I got
a book too a book came in for my boy
Chris so who's helping out on the Sunday
night episodes and that's it guys I
appreciate you guys :
I love you we'll get into some more
calls a lot of them came in we'll get
into some of them on and on Monday but
thank you guys for listening to this
past weekend on the way out I'm gonna
take us out with y'all want to hear the
rap again every want that Chris I don't
know what to do
I'll let uh what do we do let's I think
we go out with the sounds that we came
in with and no offense to you Jase
average I'll put the I'll put the wrap
up separately in a separate clip
and and this is a oh holy night that
piano for epidemic sounds from epidemic
sounds but before we go I got to also
tell you that and this is the truth man
a lot of movies they're not good
a lot of sequels remakes they keep doing
it it's ineffective you know they want
uh you know sleeping with the enemy nine
and nobody's even sleeping together
anymore it's just two people just
jerking each other off somewhere and
they're not even enemies they're friends
that's how bad some of these sequels
have gotten and there's other ones too
pig babe babe pig in the city nothing
now it's bade the last one was babe
bacon for sale and that's the whole
series it's like the fifth installment
of the series but I'm just saying a lot
of movies are bad and it's because it's
just so hard to get anything made this
these days especially with all these
molesters working in the industry and
all these sex deviants but things have
changed now because now you can go to
live tree comm and you can become an
investor and you can pick who produces
who stars in who casts and what the plot
lines are you can have a say and what is
actually created and have a piece of the
back end so that means that you can
invest it's almost like fantasy football
but for film you can invest in what you
see on the silver screen and you can own
a piece of it and have some return have
some actual return on your investment
it's like outsourcing movies to the
universe go check it out live tree
dot-com thank you guys again go to theof
on comm slash store we got some new on
word shirts that are up there I got a
couple of dates right here I'm gonna be
at the Brea Improv in Brea California
and that's January 11th through the 14th
January 18th through the 20th I'll be at
Jacksonville Florida at the new comedy
club February 16th and 17th I'll be in
La Jolla California at the La Jolla
Comedy Store 16th 17th and 18th and then
also in early April April 6 and 7 I'll
be in Tampa and that's going to be at
Rock Brothers brewery those tickets are
not none of those tickets are on or for
sale yet on my website but they will be
here
within the next few days happy Holidays
to you thank you guys so much I love you
be good yourselves you deserve it man we
all deserve it you know be that baby
show up and be that beautiful charming
baby but be a man know that you're gonna
become a man know that you're gonna make
a difference be at all you can be at all
you just have to do it for one day just
Christmas
[Music]